Today we learned about the mitigation rule,
particularly in the context of anticipatory repudiation.
Well first examine the pre UCC case of reliance Cooper Ridge versus treat and
eight circuit decision from 1952 well then learn about how the UCC treats
mitigation and how the reliance cooperage case might be decided.
Under the UCC.
Mitigation is the principle that a party that has suffered a loss has to take
reasonable actions to minimize that loss,
uh,
or at least damages will be limited as if they had taken such action.
For example,
suppose Sarah contracts with the bakery to buy a hundred cupcakes but decides to
back out of the contract at the last minute.
The cupcakes have already been made.
The mitigation rule suggests that the bakery should try to sell the a hundred
pupcakes cupcakes to someone else before they go bad,
or at least that her damages will be limited to those damages that she would
have incurred if she had a sold them or tried to sell them.
So the bakery wouldn't be entitled to damages for all the cupcakes.
Just the damages that it couldn't mitigate.
In other words,
the cupcakes it couldn't sell from an efficiency perspective,
uh,
the mitigation rule certainly makes sense.
We want to create incentives for the aggrieved party to minimize damages and
avoid waste.
Plaintiff Appellant Reliance Cooper Ridge and defendant appellee treat entered
into a written contract in this case under which defendant agreed to produce and
deliver 300,000 White Oak Bourbon staves.
The staves are the things that go into barrels that makeup barrels then that
these would be uh,
uh,
delivered by December 31st,
1950 at a price of $450 per thousand.
Staves.
Subsequently,
the defendant seller repudiated the contract by letter and phone on October six
1950.
Plaintiff informed defendant that they would hold him to strict compliance of
their promise.
Defendant never replied or or or performed at trial.
Plaintiff requested damages of the difference between the contract price and the
market price on December 31st the date of contractual performance was do the
trial.
Judge refused instructing the jury that if they found that the defendant
repudiated the contract,
then the measure of damages should be the difference between the contract price
and the lower market price plaintiff could have obtained.
Upon learning of the repudiation,
the jury awarded plaintiff $500 and the instant court reversed.
The main issue in this case is whether the plaintiff was under an unconditional
duty to mitigate damages.
Upon learning of defendant's anticipatory repudiation,
the court held for the plaintiff,
there is no obligation to mitigate damages until there are damages to mitigate
and there are no damages accrued in this case until the date of performance.
It's possible for us to break down the court's reasoning into two inquiry's.
First,
the court held that a buyer upon repudiation by the seller may sit and wait in a
rising market until the date due for performance and recover damages based upon
the difference between the contract price and the market price at that date.
Second,
the court held that the buyer did not have a duty to mitigate damages by
purchasing stays elsewhere on October six earlier than called for in the
original contract.
When the market price was lower.
What's the rule under the UCC under section two six 10 the non breaching party
has given the option to wait a commercially reasonable time after the
repudiation or to cancel or and seek damages.
It is not clear what happens if the buyer Wa waits for more than a commercially
reasonable time and does not cancel.
Also under section two seven 13,
a buyer is only awarded the difference between the market price at the time when
the buyer learned of the breach and the contract price.
The opinion in the reliance Cooper's case said that the buyer had no duty to
mitigate even if he accepted the anticipatory repudiation as an actionable
breach of the contract.
Is that consistent or inconsistent with the UCC?
Well,
it's probably inconsistent with UCC.
While at common law,
the promise he can resist repudiation,
uh,
which remember is like an offer to cancel,
which the promise he can reject.
But under two seven,
13,
the repudiation can only be,
we be resisted for a commercially reasonable time.
After that time passes that non repudiating buyers damages should not increase
because the buyer failed to mitigate damages.
In other words,
the UCC is likely to to deem that the buyer learned of the breach at the time a
commercially reasonable time to wait performance that expired.
Any waiting after that is done is that the buyer is at risk that the market
price may turn against the buyer after the buyer learns of the sellers breach,
the buyer takes the risk of market fluctuations at his own peril.
If the market price decreases after the date,
the breach is known,
the damages should not decrease.
If the market price increases after the date the breach is known,
the buyer will not get any enhancement in damages under the UCC,
a buyer has another option for damages after breach in addition to two seven 13
under section two seven 12,
uh,
there is the option of cover two section.
This cover damages is describes when a buyer procurers a substitute for the
promised performance.
UCC Section two seven 12 says that after a buyer covers the damages he is owed
is the difference between the cost of the substitute goods and the contract
price.
Let's go through an example to see how this would work.
Remember that reliance signed the contract with treat for $450 per thousand
stays.
Now suppose reliance on September 1st,
1950 had canceled the contract because of treats.
Anticipatory breach and reliance purchased 300,000 barrels,
stays at $500 and $25 per thousand from another producer on December 31st,
1950 the market price had dropped back to $450 per thousand.
Uh,
what damages would result if the buyer had covered in this way?
Well,
if the conditions of the UCC two seven 12 one are met,
if this was,
if the purchase was done in good faith and it was reasonable,
then the uh,
damages should be the difference between the contract price of $450 and the
cover price of $525.
Without knowing more,
it was probably reasonable for reliance as a buyer to cover at the market price
of $525 even though it turned out that it would have been cheaper,
uh,
to wait,
buyers usually don't have a crystal ball to know what will happen to the future
market price.
What damages would result if the buyer failed to cover?
Well then damages would be determined by another UCC section,
UCC section two seven 13 in other words,
the court would evaluate what the market price was at the time of breach and
award the difference between the contract price and that market price.
The bottom line is that regardless of whether the buyer actually covers,
the buyer cannot profit from speculation and in both cases,
the remedies approximate what a reasonable cover would cost.
Now suppose that reliance still canceled the contract for breach in September
and purchase the stays at $525 per thousand.
But now instead,
imagine that the market price instead of falling,
that the market price actually increased to $750 per thousand on December 31st,
1950 instead of suing for damages under UCC section two seven 12 reliance Sue's
under section two,
seven 13 subparagraph one.
What damages would result?
Well,
the buyer can only recover damages under UCC two seven 12.
Uh,
under this kind of a hypothetical actual cover that satisfies UCC section two
seven 12 precludes recovery under UCC section two,
seven 13.
There was some ambiguity in this because section two,
seven 12 is silent on this question,
but a comment in section to section two seven 13 clarifies the issue and
basically if you pursue cover and actually go out and buy substitute goods,
you're going to be limited to two,
seven 12.
Damages.
In summary,
reliance cooperage held that there is no obligation to mitigate damages until
the date of performance.
The UCC takes a different position.
The obligation to mitigate damages starts at the time the buyer learns of the
breach.
There are two ways to calculate damages if the buyer covers and buys as a
substitute.
Good.
Then UCC section two seven 12 governs and damages is going to be the difference
between the value of the contract and the value of the substitute goods if the
buyer doesn't cover.
Then UCC section two seven 13 governs and damages is the difference between the
value of the contract and the market price of the goods at the time the buyer
learned of the breach.